look I think if you've been chanced of
the exchequer most people watching will
pay their tax pay aye like everybody
else
and for them
4.3 million pounds which is what's
alleged and a penalty
um alongside that it's a staggering
amount of money
um and I don't think it's acceptable
really to be careless with money that
pays for our teachers our nurses our
doctors whilst being not just a
government Minister but Chancellor of
the exchequer and so for all of those
reasons I think and this is not a labor
or a conservative thing in any previous
government the individual would have
stood down uh or been sacked frankly I
mean the investigation has been launched
and you want to see it run its course I
presume or do you want them to go now do
you want to circumvent her uh well look
Magnus I think notwithstanding the
investigation and I'm glad we've got an
investigation to get to the bottom of
what happened because it's still a bit
murky and because the Prime Minister has
said one thing and then we find out
something else but regardless this
amount of money when you've been chance
of the exchequer and you say you've been
careless despite the fact that offshore
trusts have been shut up in Gibraltar
and all the rest of it I'm sorry you
really ought to resign or have been
sacked so
what why is he not resigning then I mean
what's what's your opinion as to why he
is clinging on to this because as you
rightly point out there it seems to be a
bit of a distraction at the moment
what's your sense as to what's going on
here well I think I think we should be
dealing with the cost of living crisis
we should be dealing with health and the
fact that teachers are now going on
strike these are the important issues
that certainly my constituents care
about so of course it's a huge
distraction but what we've seen the time
and time again over the last 13 years
is that when they've done wrong
government ministers remain in office
they hold on and then there's a human
cry it goes on and on for days dominates
the news where we should be dealing with
far more serious issues and I'm afraid
we're here again I take no pleasure uh
in that situation but here we are again
would you be happy publishing your tax
affairs
well look I mean I'm I think if
Parliament reaches a settlement where
all MPS have to publish their tax
Affairs then fine I'm like most of the
public you know it comes out of my
salary
and I don't get much of a say in it so
I'm happy to publish my tax Affairs if
that's the determination that Parliament
reaches and you know in the past a few
weeks we've been running a program on
her project the Westminster account
since the first chance we've got to
speak to you about it
so since 2019 you've declared 347 000
pounds in extra income and the full list
of that income I think we've got on
screen now and you've got a donation of
some 50 000 pounds from a George Brown I
mean it's all there's all the public uh
domain there's no implication that
anything wrong has been done
um but who is George Brown
look the situation is this that when
you're in the opposition and other
colleagues in senior positions in the
oppositions have received donations and
actually they've received bigger
donations than me you receive those
donations to support you in your role
the truth is in opposition there's not a
lot of money
to support the researchers and staff
that help me to be the best Shadow
foreign secretary and so yes of course
there are individuals who are supportive
of what we're trying to do and they fund
uh your political Endeavors across the
board I don't think it's fair to pick on
particular individuals the names of
their public others can do that work
there are a number of people that
support me and other colleagues there's
nothing murky about that the whole point
of declaring it is to make it public
yeah but you could tell me who he is you
could say well we don't we don't his
name is public there it is
um
I'm not going to pick on a particular
individual I don't think it's fair on
them but what I would say is we're not
in a situation in our country where all
political activity is funded by the
taxpayer some of it does come from
private donations the important thing is
that it's open it's transparent people
can see where it comes from and it comes
from people who are voters in our own
country and you know you were looking
for criticism as well for what some
people will describe as having another
job with the LBC show I mean do you
think that's a fair criticism I mean it
isn't being an MP work enough I think
there is a debate uh it came up because
of the Owen Paterson Affair around MPS
who are taking sizable amounts of money
to Lobby on behalf of a company it came
up also during the whole procurement and
PPE debacle in the pandemic I don't
think
um that anyone thinks I'm lobbying on
behalf of LBC I have a show probably on
a Sunday morning when I probably should
be at church and I'm putting issues of
current affairs lots of MPS over many
years have done bits of Rock so you'd
have no problem with the actual work
that you do on that Sunday morning but
you should be I don't but I do think
it's right to have a debate about second
jobs and I do think we need to tighten
up the rules and if we determine that
MPS can no longer get paid to be
broadcasters or shouldn't write books or
shouldn't be doctors or those sorts of
things then those will be the new rules
but it's absolutely right to have that
debate because the lobbying scandals and
the procurement the procurement crisis
Jim PPE was totally totally unacceptable
just on that then lord kerslake said
that with any new incoming government he
would like to see a change in the way
that government sort of works for the
Civil Service and changing some of these
procedures I mean would you call for
that would that be something that you
might put in in your future Manifesto
well if I look at the fcdo and you hear
about the bullying that has gone on
apparently whilst Dominic Raab has been
foreign Secretary of course we've got to
get back to a situation investigation
our civil servants in the appropriate
Manner and again yes of course happy to
look at how we set up arrangements so
that people aren't coming to work
feeling intimidated or bullied